president Trump has added more to the
deficit than Joe Biden
I think of it as kovich
that is not true because we raised
numbers we raise more Revenue than CBO
projected if you bring in more money
than your projections are how are you
adding to your deficits John and if you
pay if somehow you keep cutting taxes
but more Revenue comes in the government
that math doesn't work overtime you can
have it in the first first year due to
some various accounting uh tricks but it
doesn't work that is not true the
purpose of tax policy is to raise
revenue for the federal government not
to equalize Society after the Trump tax
cuts were passed more tax revenue has
come to the federal government than at
any other time in the history of our
nation those are the facts when you have
more money in your pocket you start
spending more money than their sales tax
and a whole bunch more you start opening
more businesses then there's payroll tax
and a whole bunch more when the
government gets out of the way that's
when the economy chugs along beautifully